this is an honor lenny i'm very very  honored that on my birthday you're  playing  it's my pl man we've been friends for uh  11 years a long time  the time i called you from my uh bathtub  yes i remember that  this is let love rule i love this song  all right  [Music]  [Music]  is  can't conquer anyone  it's time to take a stand  brothers and sisters  [Music]  [Music]  love  can make a little  can't you see  we can't do it alone  [Applause]  let them  me  [Applause]  wow  uh  [Music]  let's go  [Music]  [Music]  so  wow  hey happy birthday  happy birthday  happy birthday howard wow  man let me tell you how do they stay so  tight they haven't been on the road what  are they doing you guys are tight  god damn you're ready you're good  that's the kind of music you don't want  to have stopped